partir première également pour michel
piccoli c'est la première fois qu'il va
jouer à avignon dans la cour d'honneur
du palais des papes ces textes seront
signés william shakespeare georges bigot
jusqu'à cet été
le palais des papes n'était qu'une carte
postale pour michel piccoli mais depuis
quelques jours ils visitent tous les
recoins et grimpe jusqu'au dernier
gradins comme pour se regarder jouer la
folie du roi de sicile dans le conte
d'hiver
je sais bien à moi que je me trouve je
ne suis pas le premier cocu
je sais bien qu'en ce moment même où je
parle il y en a plein qui tiennent leurs
femmes par le bras sans soupçonner qu
leur absence les écluses ont été
ouvertes et que leurs voisins monsieur
tout sourire a plongé dans leur étant si
tout ce que leur pas propre désespérer
un homme sur dix seraient perdus quand
je suis entré la première répétition
j'étais jeune j'avais un peu
d'appréhension je me suis dit comment on
fait pour pour être intime avec c'est
avec ces muet avec cet espace et puis
deux puis trois ou quatre jours que j
répète ça y est je je je me sens et très
présomptueux mais je me sens chez moi je
me sens comme ben dans un théâtre à peu
grand mais tellement tellement
harmonieux dans le gigantisme que et
puis c'est un lieu qui est tout à fait
clos j'ai juste eu manque le plafond
mais pour moi c'est pas dupes les nerfs
alors parlons maintenant du conte
d'hiver
c'est un homme qui est fou de jalousie
les joues avec l'imaginaire de ces
jalousies qui avec sa jalousie
soi-disant concrètes pour une une main
de sa femme qui s'est approché de la
main de son meilleur ami d'enfance
alors il se sent trahi et par la femme
et par l'homme
le 16 juin dernier